[Aplausos]
con una abrumador sí los legisladores de
uganda aprobaron un proyecto de ley
lgbtq modificado para que el presidente
lo
firmeeses protejamos nuestros valores
nuestras virtudes tenemos una cultura
que proteger
un comentario dirigido a occidente que
amenazó con suspender la ayuda si se
aprobaba la ley como ya hicieron en
respuesta a una legislación anterior
contra los homosexuales en 2014 esa ley
fue finalmente anulada por un tribunal
luganés pero fue revivida este año
aprobada por primera vez en marzo la ley
se ha suavizado ligeramente Como por
ejemplo permitiendo que las personas se
identifiquen legalmente como el lgbtq
pero mantienen la mayoría de las medidas
más duras incluida la pena de muerte
para ciertos actos sexuales entre
personas del mismo sexo y una pena de 20
años de cárcel por promover la
homosexualidad lo que podría amenazar el
trabajo de los activistas por los
derechos de los homosexuales
si la ley es firmada por el presidente
lo peor sería detenciones en masa de
personas lgbtiq violencia colectiva
hacia la comunidad lgbtiq poner a las
personas lgbti no sé si en campos de
concentración o en centros de
rehabilitación
el presidente Jowell y firme opositora
los derechos de las personas lgbtq ya ha
manifestado su intención de firmar la
legislación Una vez que se introduzcan
ciertos cambios entre ellos la edición
de medidas para rehabilitar o curar a
los homosexuales las minorías sexuales
de uganda se enfrentan rutinariamente a
detenciones y acoso puesto que las
relaciones entre personas del mismo sexo
ya son ilegales más de 30 de los 54
países africanos penalizan la
homosexualidad